Order!
Order in the court!
Today, we are sentencing the most nefarious
group of criminals to ever sail the Grand
Line.
We, the court of Enies Lobby, on behalf of
the prosecution: The World Government, hereby
pronounce the Straw Hat Pirates: Monkey D.
Luffy, Roronoa Zoro, Vinsmoke Sanji, Cat Burglar
Nami, Tony Tony Chopper, Nico Robin, Cutty
Flam AKA Cyborg Franky, Soul King Brook, and
former Warlord Jinbei guilty…of: everything.
Theft.
Kidnapping.
Murder.
All of the crimes.
Death is too lenient a punishment for them,
so these criminals will be locked up in Impel
Down - and Monkey D. Luffy: don’t even think
about another prison break.
We’ve upgraded security and the Warden will
be keeping a close eye on you in the newly
constructed Level 7, which Straw Hat, I assure
you is a very, very bad place with no meat
at all.
The time you all will spend there totals 7,821
years.
So - Here is the list of all crimes committed
by the straw hat pirates:
Captain Monkey D. Luffy, son of Dragon the
revolutionary.
At the age of seven, this future pirate committed
Grand Larceny when he stole and consumed an
exceedingly rare and valuable devil fruit
from the Emperor of the Sea Red Haired Shanks.
Six years.
Grand Larceny, by the way, which I’ve heard
in like a million TV shows apparently means
theft of something worth a total of $50,000
or more.
A devil fruit definitely seems rare enough
to qualify.
Roronoa Zoro.
Once a promising bounty hunter working against
the pirate menace, it seems he changed his
ways when he murdered a dog belonging to Lieutenant
Commander Helmeppo of the Marines.
And in the court of public opinion, murdering
a dog is an even more heinous action than
killing a humans.
10 years.
During Zoro’s subsequent imprisonment, Luffy
illegally freed him, a crime worthy of five
years in prison.
He then resisted arrest - this will be a common
theme in this video.
They resist arrest just about everywhere they
go.
An additional year for each of them.
Both of these pirates assaulted multiple officers
of the law.
At two years per Marine punched, an additional
twenty years.
And, on top of it all, Luffy destroyed public
property in the form of a giant statue of
Captain Axe-Hand Morgan.
Ten years.
Settle in, everyone, because that’s 53 years
already and we’ve barely even gotten started.
Now - Cat Burglar Nami.
Don’t think we’ve forgotten about her.
For petty theft of a Grand Line map from Buggy
the Clown, one year.
That’s in addition to stealing a boat from
his crewmates in what amounts to Grand Theft
Auto.
Er - Grand Theft…Naval.
2.5 years.
Did you know that Grand Theft Auto actually
does include boats?
Fun fact.
That’s not to mention another instance of
Grand Theft Naval against her own soon-to-be
crewmates on the Baratie.
Another 2.5 years.
And Nami also assaulted an officer of the
marines in Cocoyashi Village - that’s another
2 years.
Of course, that’s not to mention the 100
million berries that the Cat Burglar stole
all across the Grand Line.
And while these berries were themselves stolen
from pirates, stealing is wrong and the World
Government just wouldn’t tolerate that kind
of behavior.
This is the crew’s second instance of Grand
Larceny which makes for an additional six
years.
Vinsmoke Sanji - as a chef on the floating
restaurant, Baratie, assaulted a ranking marine
officer, Lieutenant Commander Fullbody. 2
years.
Also on Baratie, I have reports here that
Straw Hat Luffy caused property damage by
firing a cannon ball into the restaurant and
that he also broke many dishes and snuck several
plates of food without paying.
However, Zeff decided not to press charges,
so no worries.
In Loguetown, the entire Straw Hat crew, consisting
of five members at that point once again resisted
arrest, this time by Captain Smoker.
That’s two years for each of them, so an
additional ten years.
That’s 79 years in Impel Down and the Straw
Hats haven’t even arrived in the Grand Line
yet.
And once the Straw Hats arrived in the Grand
Line, their crimes became much grander as
well.
I will dismiss Roronoa Zoro’s 100 murders
on Whiskey Peak, due to that being a case
of self-defense.
However, that doesn’t make things any better
for the crew.
After arriving in the Sakura Kingdom, formerly
known as the Drum Kingdom, the crew committed
treason against the World Government by deposing
Wapol, Drum’s sovereign monarch.
That’s going to be the first of many life
sentences for Straw Hat Luffy.
We’re just going to say a life sentence
in One Piece is 100 years since the lifespans
are a bit different than the real world’s.
Also, I am 100% on a list somewhere after
googling how many years I would get in prison
for punching various world leaders.
In the Kingdom of Alabasta, Monkey D. Luffy
and his crew of five additional pirates are
each charged with resisting arrest twice,
once in Nanohana and again in the city of
Rainbase. 20 years.
That’s not to mention the immense property
damage in the Capital of Alubarna - one year.
As well as damage caused to the Tomb of the
King, a certified historical site - an additional
year.
And, of course, there’s the defeat of Sir
Crocodile, one of the Seven Warlords of the
Sea, a crime for which there is little precedent.
We’ll say a Warlord is worth half of a monarch.
50 years.
And on top of it all, there was the worst
crime of all: dining and dashing in Nanohana.
Yet another year.
Upon fleeing from Alabasta, they once again
evaded capture, but this time they fled the
scene with the aid of a vehicle.
This actually leads to a harsher sentence
due to the expenditure of government resources
in the pursuit as well as the increased danger
to law enforcement and civilians.
That’s six years for each crew member, which
now includes Nico Robin.
That’s another 36 years.
This brings the total charges to 288 years.
Starting to sweat, Straw Hats?
Because this is just a drop in the bucket.
Let us proceed with the charges.
On the island of Jaya, Monkey D. Luffy is
guilty of aggravated assault against Bellamy
the Hyena.
It just goes to show that no matter how punchable
someone’s face is, you can’t just go around
one-shotting people.
5 years.
Skypiea is not a member nation of the World
Government, but the Straw Hats also wreaked
havoc above the clouds.
To begin with, they denied paying the entrance
fee of one billion extols.
One year for bypassing tolls.
They also assaulted many officers of the law,
including Nami ramming the captain of the
White Berets with a vehicle called a waver.
6 years for assaulting the White Berets and
an additional 7 for vehicular assault.
In addition to all of this, the Straw Hats
entered the restricted location called the
Upper Yard in an example of illegal border
crossing.
1 more year.
On the shipwright island of Water 7, Cyborg
Franky committed Grand Larceny when he stole
200 million berries from…the Straw Hats…before
he joined.
There’s a surprising amount of inter-crew
theft going on with the Straw Hats.
I mean…it’s only two times, but it’s
weird that it happened twice.
6 years.
And then, oh, what do we have here…assaulting
officers of the world government.
For Luffy, Zoro, and Franky attacking CP 9
agents in Water 7, 6 years.
Then we have a case of destruction of property
where it seems that Luffy and Zoro demolished
two buildings in Water 7 during a natural
disaster.
Turns out pirates are even more destructive
to Water 7 than the Agua Laguna.
That will be an additional 5 years.
Next, on the Sea Train known as Puffing Tom,
Vinsmoke Sanji and Cyborg Franky dispatched
several Cipher Pol agents, including Jerry
of CP 6, Wanze of CP7, Nero of CP9, and in
pursuit on a second Sea Train, Roronoa Zoro
defeated the late Vice Admiral T-Bone. 8 more
years.
And that brings us…here.
To the newly reconstructed Enies Lobby.
Do you have any idea what the construction
costs are to place a building over a giant
gaping hole in the ocean?
They’re a lot.
On the old Enies Lobby, all 8 of the Straw
Hats resisted arrest.
That’s 8 years.
All of them assaulted multiple marine officers.
At an average of five soldiers and agents
attacked per crew member, that’s an additional
80 years.
Freeing a prisoner is worth an additional
5 years, so for freeing both Cyborg Franky
and Nico Robin, that’s another 10.
Oh - And how could I forget.
The big one.
For the illegal declaration of war against
the World Government, each member of the Straw
Hats earns an additional life sentence of
100 years.
Another 800 years should give them plenty
of time to reflect on their actions.
For anyone keeping track, that makes the total
charges thus far 1,230 years.
And you may think, what’s the point of even
going further?
Surely the Straw Hats will all rot in jail
if they’re there that long.
Well, I regret to inform you that this is
still nothing compared to their heinous crimes
to come.
Like the 50 years for taking Gecko Moriah
out of commission on Thriller Bark.
But then we get to Sabaody Archipelago.
Punching the king of a member nation of the
World Government like Wapol is one thing.
But the punching of St. Charlos, a Celestial
Dragon. 200 years.
And, of course, there’s the 16 years - two
per crew member - for resisting arrest once
again.
And an additional year will be tacked on for
inciting a riot.
That was a real mess that Kizaru and Kuma
had to clean up.
After Sabaody Archipelago, Luffy booked a
direct flight to Amazon Lily, the island of
women, where he engaged in the high crime
of…being a man.
How many years does a person get in prison
for being a man?
Oh well, I’m just going to say 20 years.
20 years for being a man.
And, Franky blew up one of Dr. Vegapunk’s
old labs on Baldimore.
That’s another 2.
And from one place where Luffy was absolutely
not supposed to be, he went straight to a
place he even more was absolutely not supposed
to be…and it says here on my forms that
he single-handedly conducted the largest breakout
in the entire history of Impel Down.
Of course, involved in that Luffy has yet
again insulted officers and resisted arrest
and incited a riot.
Those crimes are only 10 years.
But the charge for freeing a prisoner is 5
years, as we’ve already covered.
It says here you freed…241 prisoners.
Let’s see…241 x 5…carry the one…that’s
another 1205 years.
Of course, Straw Hat then went to the Marineford
War.
He dropped a Marine ship onto the battlefield,
damaging government property to the tune of
10 years.
He freed yet another prisoner, Portgas D.
Ace for another 5.
That comes to a total of 2,739 years in prison.
And then, wow, I’m impressed.
This pirate crew somehow managed to lay low
and didn’t commit any crimes for an entire
two years.
If they’d waited about 3 more years, they
could have beaten the statute of limitations
on some of these charges, but nope - they
just can’t help themselves.
Pirates just love committing crimes, don’t
they?
Upon the Straw Hats’ return to Sabaody,
they destroyed government property in the
form of several Pacifistas and…what a shocker:
all 9 crew members resisted arrest.
28 years.
After that, it appears the crew traveled beneath
the Red Line to Fishman Island where they
… ah, committed a coup d’etat, tying up
the monarch of Fishman Island, King Neptune,
and taking over Ryugu Castle.
For this attempted government takeover of
a member nation of the World Government, 20
years.
King Neptune decided not to press charges,
but this offense against the government will
not be tolerated at the brand new Enies Lobby
2.
On the labs of Punk Hazard, the Straw Hats
destroyed scientific property as well as committed
aggravated assault against the scientist,
Caesar Clown.
That will be an additional 7 years.
And then moving over to Dressrosa, Luffy defeated
Donquixote Doflamingo.
Doflamingo was not only a warlord.
He was the monarch of a world government member
state.
And on top of it all, he was a Celestial dragon.
This means that his defeat has earned Luffy
a combined 350 additional years in Level 7
of Impel Down.
And, in what seems to happen everywhere this
crew goes, they resisted arrest, attacked
marines, and incited riots and rebellions.
20 years for the group.
On the Island of Zou…this can’t be right…it
appears the Straw Hats defied all logic and
expectation and did not commit any crimes
on Zou.
Unbelievable.
After leaving Zou, the crew determined to
invade two Emperor Territories - those of
Big Mom and Kaidou respectively.
These are not member states of the World Government,
however Cipher Pol agents were present on
both occasions to observe the crimes of the
Straw Hats, which were shockingly similar
in both territories.
In both cases, the Straw Hats committed illegal
border crossings. 1 year each for the 10 crew
members.
In both cases, crew members stole large amounts
of food.
1 year.
In both cases, Monkey D. Luffy caused immense
property damage.
5 years.
For inciting rebellion against the government
of Wano Country, 10 years.
For aggravated assault against many, many
individuals: 30 years.
And for wedding and/or party crashing…let’s
just say another year.
And for creating a power vacuum in the world
powers by defeating Big Mom and Kaidou, an
additional 200 years.
They are not World Government monarchs, but
they were crucial to balancing the complex
forces of the globe…and that balance is
now out the window.
This brings us to Egghead Island, the government-owned
lab run by Dr. Vegapunk.
For the combined crimes of resisting arrest,
attacking marine officers, breaking into a
top-secret government facility, and aiding
a known criminal in the form of Dr. Vegapunk
who defied government orders…you’ve earned
an additional 150 years.
For attempting to attack one of the Five Elder
Stars, Jay Garcia Saturn, another 300 years.
Of course, there are a few other high crimes
that the Straw Hats have committed.
For flying the Jolly Roger and acting in defiance
of the World Government - 10 years for each
Straw Hat crew member.
100 years.
In addition to that, there’s a 100 year
life sentence for Nico Robin for possession
of state secrets - due to her ability to read
the poneglyphs.
So far, that brings us to 4,171 years of rotting
away in Impel Down.
Plenty of time for these pirates to soak in
the guilt of their actions until their dying
breath.
Except perhaps the skeleton.
Does he even breathe?
Of course, I’ve left one crime out.
The long-nosed one…Captain Usopp.
Wait, do they have two captains?
Oh, he goes by God, now?
Very humble.
Anyway, Usopp: The false reporting of a crime,
such as that pirates are attacking your village,
is a misdemeanor offense punishable by up
to 1 year in prison.
Evidently you did this every single day for
ten years, which adds up to 3,650 years in
prison.
This brings each of your years in the depths
of Impel Down to 7,821 years.
Though I have heard rumors, that this man
has even allied himself with the Giants of
Elbaf, and so before I can dismiss this Court,
to see the true threat that these pirates
are, we are next going to watch this video
right here about all the things that will
happen on the island of Elbaf.